♪
>> Tucker: TIME NOW FOR "FINAL
EXAM," WHERE WE DIABOLICALLY PIT
THE NEWS EXPERTS AGAIN EACH
OTHER LIKE FERAL MONKEYS IN A
CAGE.
JOINING ABBY AS HER FRIEND
RAYMOND ARROYO, FOUNDER OF THE
BOOK THE WISE MEN WHO FOUND
CHRISTMAS.
I'M NOT GOING TO EXPRESS ANY
PREFERENCE AT ALL -- OBVIOUSLY
I'M VOTING FOR ABBY.
[LAUGHS]
LET ME SEE WHAT THE RULES ARE.
HANDS ON BUZZERS, ASK THE
QUESTIONS, ALL OF THEIR MULTIPLE
CHOICE.
THE FIRST PERSON WHO BUZZES GETS
TO ANSWER.
YOU HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL I'M
FINISHED ASKING THE QUESTION AND
ALL THE POSSIBLE ANSWERS BEFORE
BUZZING IN.
CORRECT ANSWER IS ONE POINT OR
WE PUNISH YOU FOR A WRONG ANSWER
BY SUBTRACTING.
FIRST TO TEN WINS.
>> CAN I HIT THE BUZZER OUT OF
HIS HAND?
>> Tucker: PHYSICAL VIOLENCE
IS, I THINK, JUDGES ARE SAYING
THAT'S AGAINST THE RULES.
BUT WE'LL FIND OUT.
HERE'S THE FIRST QUESTION.
IN AN INTERVIEW THIS WEEK,
KAMALA HARRIS COMPLAINED ABOUT
THE SECURITY MEASURES THAT GO
ALONG WITH BEING AS FAMOUS AS
SHE IS AS VICE PRESIDENT.
WHAT'S THE ONE THING SHE SAYS
SHE MISSES MOST?
, LATE-NIGHT VISITS TO
TACO BELL.
P, SENDING AND RECEIVING EMOJIS.
SEE, DRIVING A MERCEDES.
WHICH IS IT?
>> MY BUTTON IS BROKEN.
>> YOU GOT A THAT DUMB ACTION.
I THINK IT'S THE LATE-NIGHT
TRIPS TO TACO BELL.
>> Tucker: ISN'T?
THAT SOUNDS LIKE A PRETTY GOOD
GUESS.
IS IT LATE-NIGHT VISITS TO
TACO BELL >> IS IT TRUE THAT YOU
CAN NO LONGER SEND EMOJIS?
>> I HAVE NOT RECEIVED DIRECTLY
IN EMOJI IN A YEAR AND A HALF.
>> Tucker: SHE IS NOT RECEIVED
SHE IS NOT GOING TO TO THE
TACO BELL WEED VISITS.
QUESTION TWO.
WHICH SITTING UNITED STATES
SENATOR JUST VIDEOED HIM OR
HERSELF CHUGGING A BEER AFTER
RECEIVING THE COVETED
ENDORSEMENT FROM A GROUP OF
TAVERN OWNERS IN THE MIDWEST.
EIGHT, AMY KLOBUCHAR.
B, RON JOHNSON.
SEE, FAMED BEER DRINKER
ELIZABETH WARREN.
>> I'M IN A GO WITH B BECAUSE
BEER STARTS WITH B AND I THINK
IT'S A GOOD OPTION.
RON JOHNSON ALSO LOOKS LIKE HE
COULD THROW A FEW BACK.
>> Tucker: I LIKE THE WAY YOU
GUESS, ABBY.
ARE YOU CORRECT OR NOT?
>> CHEERS.
>> NOTHING SAYS BEER LIKE A SUIT
AND TIE.
>> I'M KIND OF UPSET IT WASN'T
ELIZABETH WARREN.
>> Tucker: GOOD GUESS.
BECAUSE HE IS FROM WISCONSIN
WHERE THEY DO DRINK A FEW BEERS.
QUESTION THREE, IN A NEW
INTERVIEW A WOMAN CALLED KAREN A
LANE JOHNSON, KNOWN TO SOME AS
WHOOPI GOLDBERG, SAID THAT WHEN
SHE FINALLY RETIRES FROM THE TV
PROGRAM SHE'S DISGRACED FOR SO
MANY YEARS SHE WOULD LIKE TO
BECOME A U.S. AMBASSADOR TO
EGYPT OR WHICH OTHER COUNTRY?
THIS IS FOR TWO POINTS.
A, SPAIN.
B, ITALY.
SEE, GREECE.
>> IT MUST BE ITALY.
SHE WAS SEEN SISTER ACT AND
THERE ARE A LOT OF NUNS THERE IN
ITALY.
SO MAYBE SHE'S TRYING TO DO SOME
RESEARCH.
SHE'S DOING A NEW SISTER ACT
MOVIES SO THIS COULD BE A
PROFESSIONAL VISIT.
>> Tucker: RAYMOND!
I LIKE HOW BOTH OF YOU EXPLAIN
THE THOUGHT PROCESSES THAT LEAD
TO YOUR GUESSES.
LET'S SEE IF YOU ARE CORRECT.
>> ONE DAY IF I MAKE SOME MONEY
I WANT TO BE AN AMBASSADOR.
I'M SERIOUS.
I THINK I'D LIKE TO BE AN
AMBASSADOR TO EITHER EGYPT OR
ITALY.
>> OH!
>> Tucker: SO NOW WERE AT 1-1.
SO REMOVING THIS ALONG,
ACCELERATING FAST.
QUESTION FOUR, UNSOLVED STOMACH
SMALL TOWN HAS ERECTED A 17-FOOT
STATUE TO CELEBRATE CHEETAHS.
IS IT IN CANNATA, TO OUR NORTH.
B, THE SMALL MOUNTAINOUS NATION
OF SWITZERLAND, OR A PLACE
CALLED INTERCOURSE PENNSYLVANIA,
THAT C.
>> I HAVE TO GO WITH
INTERCOURSE, PENNSYLVANIA.
>> IF IT HAD CHEESE DUST ON IT
IT WOULD WORK.
BIKO INTERCOURSE, PENNSYLVANIA.
>> Tucker: WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
IS, WHEN IN DOUBT, GO FOR
INTERCOURSE.
>> HOLY SMOKES.
NOT TUCKER, WHAT HAPPENS?
I LOSE.
>> Tucker: ABBY IS AT ONE, YOU
ARE AT ZERO.
TIEBREAKER IF YOU WIN THIS,
RAYMOND.
>> I THINK WE NEED A RECOUNT.
>> YOU GOT ONE FOR RON JOHNSON,
THAT WAS EARLY ON.
>> Tucker: I'M NOT A MATH GUY.
SO I'M JUST GOING TO MOVE US
INTO THE FINAL QUESTION.
BILLINGS, MONTANA, MANDATORY L
ALABAMA DOG BREEDER WAS SHOCKED
WHEN HIS FRENCH BULLDOG GAVE
BIRTH TO A PUPPY THAT WAS AN
EXTREMELY UNUSUAL COLOR.
HEY, GREEN.
B, PURPLE, SIKH, BLUE.
>> I THINK THE PUPPY WOULD HAVE
TO BE BLUE.
YOU DON'T HAVE GREEN OR PURPLE
PUPPIES, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: Q COULD HAVE
CLIFFORD THE BIG RED PUPPY.
LET'S ROLL TAPE.
>> WHEN I FIRST SAW THE DOG, I
WAS LIKE, I THOUGHT IT WAS OR
SOMETHING.
>> SHE'S SO ADORABLE.
>> ARE WE SURE SHE DIDN'T SPRAY
PAINT THEM?
>> SHE'S A FRENCH BULLDOG.
>> THAT'S NOT REAL.
IT LOOKS LIKE SHREK'S PUPPY.
>> Tucker: IT IS GREEN.
THAT MEANS ABBY WINS!
THAT'S NOT TO DETRACT FROM HER
DEEP AFFECTION FOR YOU RAYMOND.
ABBY WINS THE FABLED AND COVETED
JOHN FETTERMAN NECK BULGE MUG.
MAY IT BRIGHTEN YOUR MORNINGS.
I DARE YOU TO DRINK COFFEE OUT
OF THAT.
THANK YOU BOTH IT WAS GREAT TO
SEE YO